- And our next guest spent
11 seasons as Phil and Claire
Dunphy's lovable teenage
daughter on "Modern Family."
Let's say a big hello to Sara
Hyland everybody, give it up.
(crowd cheering)
- Hello
First of all,
I love your whole look right now.
The glasses there, you look
like a Charlie's Angel,
like I'm into it.
- Oh
- Yeah, and are you in a recording studio?
Is that what's happening?
- I don't have a home office yet
because I never needed one before.
So I am in my fiance's recording studio.
- Okay, I was like, I like
your whole vibe I'm into it.
And hey actually recently
turned 30, right?
So happy late birthday.
- Yes, thank you so much.
I'm so excited to
finally living in my 30s.
I've been wanting to
go since I was like 26.
- Okay that was my next
thing I was gonna say to you.
Were you just dying to
get out of your 20s.
I appreciated all that it offered,
but I was very glad to see them go.
- Yes, I am very glad to see my 20s go.
I had some amazing times,
but I also had some really horrible times
and I just, when I was
26, I was just like,
I can't wait until I turn 30
because I know in my heart, my soul,
everything I'm going to
be in a much better place.
And I very much am minus
the global pandemic.
That is something that I did
not wanna see When I turned 30.
- Yeah.
- But I have an amazing fiance.
The best dogs in the world,
except for maybe Amanda's, Amanda's dog.
- The little I know Australian
shepherd, a little mix.
Oh God no, so cute.
- So sweet.
But yeah, like I'm unemployed right now
didn't think I was gonna
be unemployed when am 30,
but you know what?
- You know what?
I think a lot of people
are unemployed right now,
so I think this has been
you know really crap year
for employment.
So at least you're not alone there.
But wait but speaking of employment,
the "Modern Family" ended
last year after 11 seasons
and 22 Emmys.
That's amazing.
Like do y'all.
And I imagine after that many seasons
of being around each other
and especially growing
up around them, like,
do y'all keep in touch?
- We do, we have a group chat.
I actually just,
I FaceTimed Ed and we and
O'Neill and we FaceTimed for like
an an hour, at least an hour,
like around my birthday.
And it was just so sweet.
He's so funny, everyone.
We like to keep in touch.
I'm probably the most
annoying person on it
'cause I'm, I have a confession.
I'm a multitextor.
- Oh, me too.
Yeah you're me on the voice coach text.
Yup, we have a text group
at the voice coaches,
it doesn't matter what season it is,
whatever coaches are involved,
I'm the one that's like blue, blue, blue
and then there's like one
gray, blue, blue, blue
one gray,
its like, its me.
Its just like my thought,
I type as I think
- Me too
- And I'm so sorry for
that but it bugs me.
I just don't have a filter.
- Yeah, me neither.
I know, well, somebody has got to be us
let's might as well be us.
Alright, well, you recently
teamed up with Olay
to support women and
whatever they have to face.
So what does that mean to you?
- Oh, it means the world to me,
I love partnering with brands
that do good for the world
and Olay has given millions of dollars
to help close the gender
pay gap for women in STEM,
for things like scholarships
and study programs
and they've donated products
to frontline healthcare workers.
So it's really important
to me to be in line with
a company and a brand that
has the same outlooks as I do,
and that wants to contribute
to better the world.
And women justices are so important to me
and as women we really
need to stick together
and stand up for each other.
And I think for me, it's like, RuPaul,
if you can't love yourself,
how the hell you can love anybody else?
Can I get an amen?
- Yeah
- And so skincare for me is like
the biggest act of self
love that I do for myself
every single day.
So that's why just teaming up with Olay
with this partnership with
Walgreens has been so special
and just kind of, I don't know, perfect.
- Yeah, well, I'm gonna you right now
I don't know what you're
using but you don't look 30,
you look 21
and you're gonna have
to tell us your secret,
like what's your Olay
products that you use.
My favorite product is the
college peptide 24 face moisturizer.
It has become a staple
in my nighttime routine
because it helps improve
the texture of my skin.
What's the like another
product to you like?
What's the second one you would
advise somebody to go get?
That the Retinol 24 night serum.
- Oh, okay.
- That one keeps my skin
hydrated for 24 hours
and it leaves my skin
smoother and brighter.
- I'm into that part.
Well, to everyone in our house seats,
I've got some news that will
instantly brighten your skin.
Olay is giving all of you a
$50 gift card to walgreens.com.
So you can try Sara's
favorite Olay products.
You're welcome.